No es un líder muy conocido y no dirige un
gran estado sino más bien un país relativamente
pequeño. Y formalmente ni siquiera es el
líder máximo del país.
Sin embargo, amigos, a pesar de ello, el pasado
día 2 de junio de 2019, el New York Times
publicó un reportaje en el que consideraba
a Mohammed bin Zayed como el líder político
árabe más poderoso del mundo.
Incluso por encima del nuevo líder de facto
de Arabia Saudita, Mohammed bin Salman, del
que ya os hemos hablado en VisualPolitik en
alguna que otra ocasión [Os dejo vídeos
en la descripción]
El caso es que tras el reportaje publicado
en el New York Times nos hicimos algunas preguntas:
¿Quién es realmente Mohammed bin Zayed?
¿Cuáles son las claves de su poder? ¿Es
realmente el líder político árabe más
poderoso del mundo?
Atentos.
Mohammed bin Zayed es el príncipe heredero
de Abu Dhabi, el emirato más rico y poderoso
de los Emiratos Árabes Unidos.
También es el comandante supremo adjunto
de las fuerzas armadas de Emiratos y el Presidente
del Consejo Ejecutivo de Abu Dhabi, es decir
el Presidente del gobierno de Abu Dhabi. Casi
nada.
Y es que, amigos, sus capacidades políticas
junto a la mala salud de su hermano mayor,
el jeque Khalifa bin Zayed, le han convertido
en el líder de facto de Abu Dhabi y por extensión
de todos los Emiratos Árabes Unidos.
(Los Emiratos Árabes Unidos son un pequeño
país con un tamaño parecido al de Panamá
o Carolina del Sur, situado en el Golfo Pérsico.
Es un país que está formado a su vez por
7 emiratos diferentes de los que con mucha
diferencia los dos más conocidos son Abu
Dhabi y Dubai.
De hecho, a pesar de ser 7 los emiratos que
forman el país, lo cierto es que a nivel
político Abu Dhabi es con mucha diferencia
el emirato más importante, ¿por qué? Lo
vamos a ver en este vídeo, pero os adelantamos
ya un motivo de muuuucho peso: Abu Dhabi concentra
más del 90% de todas las reservas de petróleo
de Emiratos Arabes.)
Pero de todo eso hablaremos más tarde. De
momento, regresemos a Mohammed bin Zayed.
Este personaje nació en el año 1961 y fue
el tercer hijo del jeque Zayed bin Sultan,
el primer presidente de los Emiratos Árabes
Unidos.
Desde muy joven enfocó su carrera hacía
el ejército, donde llegó a convertirse en
piloto de las fuerzas aéreas. Y es precisamente
ahí donde arrancó su carrera política.
En 1991, justo después de la invasión de
Kuwait por parte del Irak de Saddam Hussein,
el entonces comandante de las fuerzas aéreas
emiratíes aterrizó en Washington con una
misión:
Comprar todos los equipos militares que fueran
posibles. Misiles Hellfire, helicópteros
Apache, aviones F16. Querían el paquete completo.
Desde ese preciso momento, nuestro protagonista
se convirtió en uno de los aliados más estrechos
de Washington no sólo en los países árabes
sino incluso de todo el planeta.
(Hablamos de un líder político que con el
paso de los años se ha convertido en uno
de los íconos del reformismo y la apertura
en el mundo árabe. Bajo su gestión, Abu
Dhabi ha seguido los pasos aperturistas, tanto
en materia económica como civil de Dubái.
E incluso en algunas cuestiones ha ido más
allá.
Tal vez la mejor prueba de ello sea la visita
del propio Papa Francisco a Emiratos, de la que ya os
hablamos hace poco tiempo aquí en VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo que ha liderado
un programa de reformas que ha convertido
a Emiratos tal vez en el país más aperturista
y próspero del mundo árabe, Mohammed bin
Zayed también defiende a capa y espada una
idea que puede resultarnos al menos controvertida:
que hoy por hoy el mundo árabe no está preparado
para la democracia.)
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Según bin Zayed, el aperturismo en el mundo
árabe sólo puede ser liderado por regímenes
autoritarios.
Promover democracias no haría más que alimentar
a grupos fundamentalistas que terminarían
ganando las elecciones. Es una idea que defiende
activamente y que ha marcado profundamente
la agenda exterior de Emiratos en los últimos
años.
Pero… amigos, dicho esto creo que ahora
sí tenemos que empezar a responder a la pregunta
clave de este vídeo: ¿Donde recala y cuánto
poder tiene realmente este personaje?
Veamos cuáles son las 3 principales claves,
los cimientos de su poder.
Atentos.
(1. EL PODER DE LA CARTERA)
No creo que os resulte extraño a ninguno
si os digo que el dinero siempre ha sido uno
de los elementos de poder más importantes
que existen.
Pues bien, si por algo han sido famosos los
países árabes ha sido por derrochar cantidades
indecentes de dinero en todo tipo de cosas,
caprichos o proyectos que luego no iban a
ninguna parte, ¿verdad?
Pues, amigos, en este caso además de gastar
mucho dinero en todo tipo de proyectos públicos,
lo que también han hecho los Emiratos ha
sido ahorrar e invertir buena parte de su
dinero por todo el planeta.
Pero la pregunta es, ¿Exactamente cuánto
dinero tiene ahorrado los Emiratos y Abu Dhabi
en sus fondos soberanos? ¿De cuanto diantres
estamos hablando?
[Para los que no lo sepáis, Un fondo soberano
es un fondo de inversión que un gobierno
crea para invertir sus ahorros en activos
que tienen la misión de generar rentabilidad.
Vamos, como un fondo de inversión para cualquier
ahorrador.]
(El caso es que según las últimos estimaciones,
los fondos soberanos de Emiratos Árabes Unidos
acumulan inversiones por valor de más de
1,3 billones de dólares, billones hispanos.
De esta cantidad algo más de 900.000 millones
de dólares se concentran en los dos principales
fondos soberanos de Abu Dhabi:
La autoridad de inversiones de Abu Dabhi que
controla casi 700 mil millones y que es el
tercer mayor fondo soberano de todo el planeta;
Y el fondo Mubadala con algo más de 220 mil
millones de dólares norteamericanos.)
Hablamos de una fortuna descomunal. Más de
900 mil millones ahorrados por el Emirato
de Abu Dhabi e invertidos por todo el mundo
en acciones, deuda, edificios, autopistas,
puertos, aeropuertos, bancos, hospitales,
hoteles, fábricas, minas, incluso heladerías…
de todo.
Y eso es, precisamente, lo que explica noticias
como estas:
(Abu Dhabi paga 495 millones a Abertis por
el 20% de su filial chilena. El País)
(La Autoridad de Inversión de Abu Dhabi invertirá
$ 50 mil millones en la India. El fondo de
Abu Dhabi, uno de los fondos soberanos más
grandes del mundo, destinará $ 50 mil millones
a la India, especialmente a infraestructura
y capacidad de procesamiento de alimentos.
Y ojo porque el poder no solo está en tener
la cartera llena sino en controlar un activos
y empresas de todo tipo por todo el planeta
y también en ser un dinero muy pero que muy
codiciado por la mayoría de los gobiernos.
[¿Quien no quiere un cuantos miles de millones
de inversión en su país? Eso sí que es
diplomacia.]
En cualquier caso hay un detalle que no nos
podemos saltar.
Veréis, el Emirato de Abu Dhabi tiene una
población de apenas 2,7 millones de personas,
de las cuales poco más de medio millón tienen
la nacionalidad emiratí.
Es decir, los ahorros del Emirato de Abu Dhabi
tan solo en sus dos principales fondos soberanos
ascienden a más de 340 mil dólares por cada
habitante y a más de 1,6 millones por cada
ciudadano de Abu Dhabi con la nacionalidad
emiratí.
1,6 millones de dólares.
Llevan ahorrando desde el año 1976.
[Y ojo porque a pesar de estar sentados sobre
semejante cantidad de dinero se toman muy
en serio que el gobierno no tenga déficit
público.]
Desde luego mucho más en serio que en Argentina.
(Abu Dhabi registrará un superávit
en 2019 gracias a los esfuerzos de consolidación
presupuestaria.)
Pero amigos, esta no es la única clave del
poder de Mohammed bin Zayed.
(2. EL PODER DE LA FUERZA)
Tal vez es la cara menos conocida de los Emiratos,
pero durante los últimos años este pequeño
país se ha ganado el apodo de la “pequeña
Esparta”.
Y es que veréis el ejército de Emiratos
es muy pequeñito sí, tiene poco más de
60.000 soldados.
Pero, amigos, durante las últimas dos décadas
bajo la dirección de Mohammed bin Zayed y
un montón de expertos entre los que se encuentra
el mismísimo ex secretario de defensa de
los Estados Unidos, Jim Mattis, este ejército
se ha reestructurado con una idea:
ser un ejército pequeño pero muy bien equipado,
ágil y bien entrenado.
(Para ello cada año el presupuesto militar
de Emiratos supera los 20.000 millones de
dólares. Lo que les ha permitido comprar
todo tipo de equipos extranjeros:
70 F-16 actualizados con la última tecnología;
otros 70 Mirage; 30 apaches, 19 chinook, más
de 400 tanques Leclerc, 76 scorpions, miles
de vehículos blindados de todo tipo, decenas
de drones, el sistema antimisiles patriot…
hasta se han comprado la joya de la corona
el sistema antimisiles THAAD, uno de los sistemas
más modernos de los Estados Unidos. El mismo
que la potencia norteamericana desplegó en
Corea del Sur provocando un enorme enfrentamiento
con China.)
Y esto es solo el comienzo, ahora por ejemplo
están detrás del F-35.
De hecho, Emiratos es después de Arabia Saudi
el segundo mayor comprador de tecnología
y equipos militares de los Estados Unidos.
Pero, vale, es verdad.
Si por algo han sido conocidos tradicionalmente
los ejércitos árabes ha sido por gastarse
un montón de dinero en equipos que a los
que a la hora de la verdad no eran capaces
de sacar provecho.
Por eso, otra prioridad de Mohammed bin Zayed
ha sido lograr que el ejército emirati esté
bien entrenado. ¿Y que creeis que han hecho
para conseguirlo?
Pues amigos además de pagar todo tipo de
entrenamientos y cursos de formación en el
extranjero, el ejército emiratí se ha hinchado
a entrar en combate durante los últimos años
especialmente de la mano de los mismísimos
Estados Unidos.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
(Desde el año 2003 Emiratos ha desplegado
tropas de elite en Afganistán, enviado tropas
a Somalia para combatir la piratería y tras
Estados Unidos ha sido el país que más misiones
aéreas ha llevado a cabo contra el Estado
Islámico. Siempre mano a mano con Estados Unidos.
Y no solo eso, recientemente también han
intervenido por su propia cuenta en Libia,
en el norte del Sinaí en Egipto y de forma
masiva en Yemen.)
Por supuesto también han contratado a un
montón de expertos de todo el mundo, de tal
forma que algunas unidades están incluso
bajo mando de oficiales extranjeros. Es decir
han fichado a sus propios oficiales.
Es el caso, por ejemplo, del General Toumajan
un ex teniente coronel del Ejército
de los Estados Unidos que hoy está al mando
de la división de helicópteros emiratí;
o del australiano Mike Hindmarsh, que dirige
la Guardia Presidencial.
El resultado es que hoy el ejército emiratí
es considerado uno de los ejércitos no solo
mejor equipados sino también mejor entrenados
de toda la región.
[Vamos, tan solo por detrás de Israel, país
al que por cierto están comprando tecnología.]
Y eso no es todo.
Además, para ganar autonomía las autoridades
emiratíes han reestablecido el servicio militar
obligatorio y han puesto mucho dinero sobre
la mesa para desarrollar toda una industria
armamentística nacional.
Una industria militar propia.
[Eso sí, siempre de la mano de las grandes
multinacionales y su tecnología]
(Y lo cierto es que lo están consiguiendo.
Actualmente hay casi 200 empresas de defensa
emiratíes fabricando todo tipo de equipos:
Blindados, misiles guiados, drones, aviones
ligeros… Todo fabricado en Emiratos. Ahora
incluso están tratando de desarrollar su
propio bombardero de hélices para operar
a baja altitud en misiones de contrainsurgencia.)
Pero, amigos aún más.
Emiratos ha abierto bases militares en lugares
como Yemen, Eritrea y Somaliland - lo que
no tiene precedentes - y se ha preparado para
operar junto a ejércitos mercenarios.
Mercenarios de élite liderados por Erik Prince,
el fundador y propietario de la compañía
Blackwater, que complementan las capacidades
de su propio ejército.
(Emiratos envía secretamente mercenarios
colombianos a la guerra de Yemen.)
En fin ya lo veis, este es el cambio que está
produciendo en el ejército emiratí y lo
que les ha valido el calificativo de la “pequeña
Esparta”.
Todo de la mano de nuestro protagonista.
Pero esta no es su última “bala”.
(3. GEOESTRATEGIA AL PODER)
Con unas reservas probadas de más de 97.000
millones de barriles, Emiratos tiene bajo
su subsuelo las séptimas mayores reservas
de petróleo convencional del planeta.
Actualmente están produciendo unos 3 millones
de barriles cada día y esperan alcanzar los
4 millones en 2020 y los 5 millones para el
año 2030. Eso es mucho, muchísimo petróleo.
Así que con todo ese petróleo y con todo
el dinero que hemos visto, Mohammed bin Zayed
se ha lanzado a toda una carrera diplomática
a lo largo y ancho de todo el planeta que
ha multiplicado en los últimos años la influencia
internacional de este pequeño país.
India, Indonesia, Etiopía… y por supuesto
Estados Unidos. Sus relaciones con la administración
Trump son formidables. Lo cierto es que con
semejantes activos bajo el brazo no hay puerta
que se le resista a nuestro protagonista.
(Y, si a todo esto le sumamos que Emiratos
se ha convertido durante las últimas dos
décadas en un importantísimo centro financiero,
comercial, logístico e incluso turístico
y que de facto al frente de todo esta este
hombre, Mohammed bin Zayed, no parece descabellado
pensar que hoy por hoy sea el líder político
árabe más poderoso del mundo.)
Desde luego, tal y como habéis visto razones
para alcanzar ese calificativo no faltan.
Eso sí, que sea el árabe más poderoso no
implica que todo le salga bien. Ni muchísimo
menos. El bloqueo a Catar ha sido un rotundo
fracaso. Pero de eso ya os hablamos en este
vídeo.
Y ahora, ahora te voy a pedir una cosa. Si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.